my mother was a bookmaker so she worked
with men and I used to admire how my
mother walked into a room in the respect
she got from men wow it wasn't a respect
that she got because she had big tits
because she laid the Lord down in that
room yeah I came from a very interesting
backlit that I didn't know when my
mother was 16 her and her sister went to
a dance in Cuba and my sister my mother
couldn't find her sister so she went
outside and some guy was raping her and
my mother broke a bottle and cut the guy
stabbed him from one side of his back to
the other
he died so I had to get my mother out of
Cuba into the states
so my mom went to like caracal first
Curacao yeah first yeah we have military
base there huge military base huge and
then she went to the states and then she
went back to Cuba with a fake identity
and everything disappeared wow so I look
at my daughter
but I think about me and I know that
that's in my blood it's in there that
that's a possibility right my my mom had
to think quick I never knew the story
until she died wow she was Fearless I
never knew the story I saw her in action
in fact yesterday she has been a strong
woman yes that was right the [__]
thing because I usually like when you go
write jokes sometimes you can't write
jokes so just sitting there licking a
pen I'll [__] just write a story yeah
you know like that's right and I wrote a
story about me and karate and how I got
into career I got into karate because I
played hooky and I got hit in the head
with a lunch box and I got stitches and
I told my mother and the next day she
walked me to a black Karate school all
black black people doing karate oh yeah
no one 69 68 New York City how's that
not a doctor as a matter of fact you
know Loranger orange this guy's one of
these black belts wow he has a show the
LeBron James he's a black dude but he
makes believe he's Brazilian a capoeira
boy yeah he insults everybody
his father was my first black belt and
his father would walk around with a
[__] wooden sword and hit you there
was no giggling allowed that's great and
I remember I got kicked in the stomach
one time and got the wind knocked out of
me and I'm like I'm not going back and
my mom grabbed me she goes you don't go
back in there I'm gonna kick in the
stomach 50 [__] times so get back in
there that's no big deal you got kicked
one time he would make you run on the
streets with your Geon
barefoot in 1968 you'd be running past
all your friends and then the next day
you go to school and your friends like
hey karate man yeah come on show us some
karate and [__] so then you'd be put on
the spot Connie you kind of had to
respect your art yeah to show your art
to your friends and you had it then and
then you decide for yourself do I
respect my art am I going to show it or
what am I going to do in this moment
that's why I love the martial arts so
much because at that time I was so
[__] up but they brought me into
something and I used to get bullied by
this kid Rudy the Haitian he was a
Haitian kid yeah Haitians can be wild
man it's risky 50 50 shot every time
with the head this is the 60s in New
York I don't even know what a Haitian is
yeah but the whole neighbor would call
them Rudy the Haitian and he was about
my age and he would beat me up like once
a month or whatever
and one day I got the karate down I let
this [__] up Jack I lit him up
with kick some [__] Double Dragon oh
yeah I got him with like 20 kicks to the
stomach and [__] and then the next time
I forward him his father came downstairs
and grabbed my arms and pinned me and
let him hit me and then his father took
me upstairs the cheat code and my mother
would wake up in the mornings take me to
school but my mom would have a bar so
she wouldn't go to bed till four in the
morning so she would do all this [__]
and then come home and take her
afternoon nap
and there's one particular day he came
upstairs knocked on my mom's door which
big mistake yeah my mom opened the door
like what's going on he's like the next
time your son hits my son I'm gonna hit
him and I'm gonna hit you
mom got a [__] kitchen knife and
chased them up the stairs I was like a
little I was like five damn I was like
crying mom's gonna get there and also my
mom came down holding a knife so that
[__] never [__] with you again
and we went inside but the lady next
door had seen everything that went down
in the apartment everybody yeah but it
was the 70s there was no camera and
Americans shut that [__] mouth there
was no rats you were not allowed to talk
to the police you were raised not to
talk to the police yeah I don't know if
they got like 10 minutes to say the cops
knocked on the door and they had my mom
in the hallway they turned her around
they were about to arrest her he kept
saying that my mother had a knife and
the little old lady came out with a with
[__] uh what do you call those
knitting and probably knitting across or
something yeah rosary beads oh yeah and
she goes I saw the whole thing she
didn't have a knife and that was it she
had a spoon she was stirring coffee
isn't that right and my mom goes yeah
see in Spanish and the cops were like
all right let it go and my mom was
telling Rudy's father in Spanish that
while my dolly went this [__] and a weak
land of Rudy's family moved from the
building we never saw the Haitians again
wow
that's not with your mom being so tough
was it like did was it tough to feel
like affection from her because
sometimes like my mom's a hard worker
right my mom delivered you know she's a
delivery woman you know she delivered
newspapers when I was a kid she delivers
magazines now
um she's always had a [__] van you
know now she's got my her husband he has
Alzheimer's you don't even know he's in
the van he's with her every day just
[__] bouncing around
in the passenger seat
she had to get a [__] second seat
belt in the stall for him because he
[__] was kind of he's getting little
he would slip out of the [__] person
and how she's got him just basically in
a [__] straight jacket just bouncing
around he has no clue where he is just
delivering [__] news on Wheels every
day you know I think he's about 90 you
know your mom still knows this mom still
does it dude and here's the worst part
bro she got a good deal on this van
right my mom likes a good deal and she
got a good deal on his van has no win
none of the side or back windows bro so
her [__] GPS is the Lord bro so she
just [__] bouncing around he's got
him in a thing but she's out there
delivering all these things man and she
just she won't not work you know like I
could tell her like look you know you
know I give her some money every month
every month but she wouldn't have
anything else to do you know it's like
her identity but then for me it was hard
to like
for me that kind of mom was hard to
connect with you know because
that she just had you know she
for me I looked at my mom as like the
mom and the dad I didn't realize when I
was a kid
but you know did you find it was tough
to like have an emotional like a a
mother-son connection when your mom is
like such a has to be such a Bravado you
know what I'm saying kinda I grew up
without a dad I had a stepdad
my mom was tough yeah my mom was very
tough in in today's world it would be
life abuse
but I'm thankful yeah same I'm thankful
yeah I'm saying everything she did
because my mom prepared me for the world
today I'm not raising my daughter I'm
preparing my daughter just in case
something happens to me hmm
my mom did a great job but she left a
lot of gaps and that's where the damage
came in right so what I did differently
is I write all the damage down I write
for my daughter
so I write every couple days when I'm
feeling what my thoughts are kind of
like Jax Teller on Sons of Anarchy yeah
so if something does happen she knows
what's going on she has all the [__]
answers she'll never she'll know the
truth you know I don't tell my daughter
my comedian and I'm showing her because
if not she's going to want to be a
[__] comic in front of the stage
right don't tell him I don't even know
like the Pre-K teacher the other day
said have your Daddy help you write it
but it's got to be clean I don't want
that [__] don't tell her because it's
gonna be all right for her to be the
class clown right I don't want her to be
the class yeah my mom dog made me fight
my mom brought a girl home for me the
first time what the [__] till this day I
can look you guys both in the eye and I
don't even know if I [__] I think I
passed out from Fear
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one